INTRO:
It’s no secret that over the past decade,
Warren Buffett hasn’t been at the top of
his game.
In fact, between 2010 and 2020, he basically
just matched the market.
This isn’t terrible performance given that
most hedge funds don’t even match the market,
but for a legendary investor with an average
annual return of 20.5%, it’s rather disappointing.
This has caused many to wonder if Buffett
has lost his touch in the new digital world.
Despite this lackluster performance over the
past decade, Buffett has actually been crushing
it in 2022.
In fact, Berkshire Hathaway is slightly positive
on the year while the overall market has been
getting slaughtered.
Currently, Berkshire Hathaway is up 3% on
the year while the S&P 500 is down 16%.
This recent move means that Berkshire Hathaway
is officially outperforming the market not
just on an yearly basis, but since the bottom
of the 2008 financial recession which is when
he quote on quote “lost his edge”.
So, here’s the top 5 reasons why Buffett
had been struggling to beat the market and
how he’s overcame these challenges.
VALUE STOCKS:
Likely one of the biggest reasons Buffett
has had trouble beating the S&P 500 is due
to his focus on value stocks.
In recent history, value stocks simply haven’t
kept up with growth stocks in terms of returns.
Between 2010 and 2020, growth stocks almost
outperformed value stocks by a full 100%.
But, while growth stocks tend to outperform
during bull markets, they also get crushed
during bear markets.
And given that the NASDAQ is currently experiencing
a bear market, it’s not surprising that
many of the high growth names have gotten
destroyed.
Since the start of the year, the growth stocks
in the S&P 500 have underperformed Berkshire
Hathaway by about 25%.
Conversely, many value stocks have performed
extremely well such as energy stocks.
Since the start of the year, the value stocks
in the S&P 500 have outperformed the overall
index by nearly 10%.
So, in the current market environment, Buffett’s
value centric investing philosophy is holding
up pretty well.
Aside from benefitting for a risk off market,
Buffett has also moved towards embracing a
few high growth tech companies himself.
If we take a look at his holdings, we’ll
see that Apple is by far his biggest position.
He currently has $133 billion in Apple which
accounts for nearly 40% of his entire portfolio.
Another mega cap company that Buffett has
recently embraced is Amazon.
His stake in Amazon isn’t nearly as large
as his stake in Apple, but it is still a billion
dollar position.
Buffett has even ventured into some more early
stage tech companies such as Snowflake which
isn’t even profitable yet.
Currently, these stocks are actually holding
back Buffett given that they’re all down
by substantial amounts.
Apple is down 20%, Amazon is down 34%, and
Snowflake is down over 50%.
So, if Buffett is able to post a positive
return with all these tech companies being
down so much, imagine what type of returns
he’ll be posting when these companies recover.
In the end, Buffett’s willingness to finally
embrace tech while also maintaining his value
positions has enabled him to enjoy the best
of both worlds.
TOO MUCH CASH:
Another major issue that Buffet has faced
over the past decade is simply putting his
money to work.
Recently, Buffett has been holding significant
amounts of cash which of course produces little
to no returns.
His cash position has gotten slightly better
over the past 2 years as it has dropped from
$128 billion to $106 billion today, but there’s
still a long way to go.
But, wait a minute, why is Buffett even having
trouble deploying his cash in the first place?
Well, at the core, Buffett is still a value
investor and though he has embraced some growth
plays, he’s not willing buy when prices
are quote “sky-high”.
Now, you might disagree with this statement
given the recent sell off, but on a historical
basis, the market is still trading for a rich
valuation.
For example, the median PE ratio of S&P 500
companies over the past 140 years is 14.89.
Today, the PE ratio of the S&P 500 stands
at 20.34 which means that the average company
is still overvalued by 33%.
Similarly, the Buffett indicator which compares
the US stock market with the US GDP suggests
that stocks are currently overvalued by 75%.
Now, I’m sure there’s gonna be comments
down below that argue that these models are
outdated due to low interest rates, excessive
money printing, and the rise of international
markets.
While you may be right, we have to acknowledge
that Buffett is more of an old school investor.
So, I think its safe to assume that he gives
at least some weight to the indicator that
was literally named after him.
Alright, so the overall market may seem overvalued
from Buffett’s perspective.
But, regardless of the market environment,
there’s always deals on the market right?
Well, there are always deals on the market,
but the problem is that these are generally
underrated small cap companies that won’t
really move the needle for Buffett.
For example, let’s say you find an extraordinary
small cap company that’s worth $1 billion.
Even if Buffett bought this entire company
and the company grew 10X within the next 10
years, he would only make $9 billion.
And while that’s an insane amount of money,
it would only grow Buffett’s overall portfolio
by a mere 2.6%.
Considering this, investing in small cap companies
is simply not a feasible option for Buffett.
He has to stick to companies that are worth
tens of billions if not hundreds of billions,
and amongst these companies, it’s been extremely
difficult to spot a deal.
One of the main ways that Buffett has been
combating this issue is buy constantly growing
his existing positions.
Last quarter, for example, he bought $600
million worth of Apple stock.
But, this can only take him so far, and sooner
or later he’s going to have to find new
companies to invest in.
BECOMING THE MARKET:
As Buffett’s portfolio continues to grow
and he concentrates on large cap companies,
one of the biggest hurdles he has to face
is unintentionally becoming the market himself.
I mean if you just keep adding large cap positions,
you basically just become the S&P 500 yourself.
Buffett currently has 48 positions in basically
every industry you can think of from tech
and retail to food and banking.
While this may not sound like a big deal,
it is given that Buffett is currently breaking
his own advice.
One of Buffett’s most famous sayings is
that “Diversficiation is protection against
ignorance.
It makes little sense if you know what you’re
doing.”
Now, I don’t think Buffett is diversifying
to protect against ignorance.
I think he’s diversifying in an attempt
to deploy as much capital as possible.
But, this naturally comes along with the unintended
consequence of limiting upside potential.
Aside from breaking his own diversification
rule, Buffett is also actively breaking his
20 slot rule.
The rule suggests that an individual’s financial
success could be improved if they could only
make 20 investments throughout their entire
life.
The idea is that if an individual’s investment
choices are heavily constrained, they would
be highly selective with each investment they
make.
And hopefully, this selectiveness would improve
their chances of making good investments.
Given that Buffett is currently holding onto
48 different positions, he’s clearly not
abiding by this rule.
But, this isn’t to say that Buffett isn’t
trying his best to limit diversification.
Even though Buffett has dozens of positions,
his portfolio is still extremely top heavy.
His top 10 positions, for example, account
for 85% of his portofolio and his top 20 positions
account for 96% of his portfolio.
In other words, all of Buffett’s investments
past the 20 slot rule only account for 4%
of his portfolio.
Despite all his efforts though, it’s only
natural that the performance of Berkshire
Hathaway gets closer and closer to that of
the market as they continue to grow and their
investments mature.
MISSING THE MARK:
On top of all these external factors weighing
on Berkshire’s performance, it should be
noted that Buffett has made a few major mistakes
himself.
For example, in the early 2010s, Buffett wanted
to get in on all the tech growth, so he decided
to buy a legacy player which was IBM.
In 2011, he announced that he purchased $10.7
billion of IBM at $170 per share.
While IBM did reach about $200 per share in
2013, it has since been on a decline, and
Buffett eventually ended up selling his shares
for a loss.
While this was no doubt a subpar investment,
Buffett also made one the worst investments
of his career within the past decade which
is of course Kraft Heinz.
While Buffett maintains that both Kraft and
Heinz were great companies fundamentally,
he has admitted that he overpaid for the Kraft
portion of the business.
Aside from paying a premium for the company,
Buffett went on to oversee a merger of the
two companies which hasn’t been all that
successful.
I have a full video on the downfall of Kraft-Heinz
if you’re interested.
But in essence, the company couldn’t keep
up with the prices of generic brands or the
healthniess of up and coming brands.
So they’ve been stuck in this weird middle
ground that doesn’t appeal to either demographic.
On top of this, Kraft-Heinz has been involved
in an accounting scandal, they’ve had to
write off massive losses, and the CEO left
during the peak of their troubles.
As you would guess, all of these issues have
resulted in Kraft-Heinz stock getting obliterated.
They’re currently down over 50% from their
peak in 2017.
Despite this horrendous performance, Buffett
has continued to vouch for Kraft-Heinz, but
it should also be noted that he has been transparent
that he would’ve sold the stock a long time
ago if he was able to easily liquidate his
massive position.
Fortunately though, it does look like Kraft-Heinz
has finally bottomed out and it’s starting
to form an upward trend.
So, hopefully, Kraft-Heinz won’t weight
down on Buffett’s portfolio moving forward.
SHIFTING PRIORITIES:
While everything we’ve covered so far in
the video are valid points, something that
we shouldn’t overlook is Buffett’s age.
Buffett is currently 91 years old.
This isn’t to say that Buffett is too old
for this or anything like that, but it does
bring up the question: How much does Buffett
even care about beating the market anymore?
When you’re over 90 years old, I suspect
that you would care a lot more about living
out the last of your days to the best of your
ability as opposed to beating some vain metric.
Now, Buffett clearly still enjoys investing
and talking about stocks.
That’s why he continues to lead Berkshire
and regularly participates in press events.
But, with that being said, I think Buffett
has several priorities that are higher than
beating the market like philanthropy.
Warren Buffett is the biggest philanthropist
in the entire world having donated a massive
$42.8 billion.
And given that Buffett is looking to donate
all of his wealth after he dies, I suspect
that his number 1 priority is to ensure that
all of his wealth ends up in the right hands.
This aligns with what he’s been recommending
as well.
After all, Buffett doesn’t even recommend
that you invest in Berkshire.
He recommends that you invest in the S&P 500
instead.
Considering this, it’s pretty clear that
Buffett isn’t exactly trying to appeal to
investors meaning that maximizing returns
is not his top priority.
At this point, it seems like he’s just looking
to see how far he can take it while having
some fun.
And it just so happens, that he’s beating
the market once again.
Do you guys think that this is just some random
fluke, or do you think Buffett will continue
to lead the market?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re a fan of Buffett’s
insane philanthropy.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.